what up space fam goals in here from
anime uproar back at it again with yet
another demonstrator video and this is a
very special one because the first
episode of demonstrators season two has
finally dropped and it was straight fire
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy demons their videos on
this channel and want to keep them
coming set your heart ablaze and smash
that like button remember that smashing
that like button is goku energy in
passing is creepy speed demon energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video you subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future demonstrator videos and
updates and while you wait for the next
demonstrator episode to drop feel free
to check out my huge and growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos in all the hashira demon moons
and much more link to that is in the
description and now without further ado
let's jump into it and there will be
spoilers for the first episode of season
2 if you haven't seen it yet so you've
been warned if you've been keeping up
with our demonstra update videos on this
channel then it should come as no
surprise that demonstrator season 2
episode 1 dropped on october 10th and
that the season started with the moog
and train arc rather than with the
entertainment district arc and if you
are having trouble finding out
funimation or crunchyroll it is under
mugen train arc rather than the title of
season 2. i covered all the details of
this upcoming season in the last update
video that i'll link in the description
of this video but yeah this anime season
will be retelling and adding to what the
demonstrator movie covered before we
actually get to the entertainment
district arc which will star the sound
hashira tangan uzui rather in the flame
hashra kyojiro rengoku for now though i
hope everyone is pleased that we get
more goku i know i am especially since
i've read the whole manga so i'm not
dying to know what happens next in the
anime i'm just here to enjoy the ride
that is the anime retelling of one of my
favorite manga the cool thing about this
first episode which was named after
kyojo rengoku is that it wasn't covered
in the film or manga this was brand new
material and it was great looking back
on the intro of this arc i definitely
feel like something like this was
missing to bridget and goku's first
introduction with the rest of the hashia
to this reintroduction of him eating
from a bento box and screaming delicious
on the train as he did before you might
have been confused about what he's doing
but by the time this first episode is
over you have a completely different
view of rengoku and his character as the
train starts moving you almost feel
privileged like you know this secret
information about him that no one else
on the train does but i'm getting ahead
of myself let's start with the beginning
of this episode which is about letting
us get to know goku better and also
about showing off some awesome animation
as well then goku is eating noodles and
screaming delicious as he does and in
this instance the cook is especially
touched by how appreciative rengoku is
for the food he even treats rengoku to
extra on the house food which shows a
and goku's positivity and b how did
goku's personality brings out the best
in others and how they can't help but
like him with his positivity and
bluntness we're told about victims on a
train and a slasher who's been killing
them kyojiro is looking for this demon
who is the culprit and he stumbles upon
bento vendors a girl and her grandmother
the grandmother speaks of demons but the
kid thinks they don't exist which is
pretty classic demon slayer ironically
the kids who seem like the realists end
up being wrong since obviously demons do
exist in this world kyodra hilariously
asks the girl point blank if she's seen
any demons this is hilarious not only
because it causes the girl to freak out
and throw a bun in his face but also
because practically every other demonstr
member would avoid bringing up demons
because they'd know they'd come off as
crazy and probably freak civilians out
nathren goku though who's clearly blunt
and straightforward and true to his
character he doesn't get mad about
getting a bun thrown in his face but
rather eats it and states how delicious
it is then goku is like the best example
of a guy who if given lemons by life
would immediately make lemonade and even
call it delicious this episode really
shines when it comes to rangoku's
relationship with other humans like
these two he is thankful they work at
night to feed people like him and thinks
that no one should hurt good people like
them such thinking led him to become a
demonstrator and protector of such
people after all his goodness and
generosity doesn't stop with nice words
though he also buys all their bento
after promising them that he will take
care of the slasher this is especially
meaningful to the vendors and the
audience because we know how they're
struggling for money and haven't had a
lot of customers thanks to the slasher
so then goku's kind gesture really means
a lot and not only does my boy buy all
the bento he even sends a bunch with his
demon sir core assistant so that he
could give it to the other core members
so he not only helped the struggling
vendors but treated the core to bento
boxes too no wonder everyone loves this
dude while he's on a train pretending to
be a bento vendor keep in mind he
brought some boxes with him a trained
personnel discovers him and is surprised
to see someone on the train it is so
hilarious when goku says that he is in
no way suspicious to the trained
personnel as if anyone who isn't
suspicious would say that he asks about
the mugen train finds out it's at a
place he's close to and he jumps out of
the train totally in no way suspicious
rangoku he gets their location where
they're working on the train and he
gives the remaining bento to the workers
soon enough a demon is sensed and he
kidnaps a kid to use as a hostage and
the demon even steps on a bento box
irritating rangoku who knows the people
who made that bento box with love it's
like the demon is just walking all over
their work and kindness this slasher
demon is a brand new demon we've never
seen before and he's interesting and
very easy to dislike his thing is he's
especially fast and he even states that
no one has stopped him and even then
goku misses with his first attack for
some slasher characterization we find
out since he turned into a demon he
hates human food and the smell of it and
as a result he hates the smell of some
humans as well rather than just not
eating them though he enjoys tormenting
the ones he won't eat he talks about a
recent victim of his but she was
actually saved by rengoku who got to her
in time and goku says she will recover
without a single scar which is a tad
unlikely if you ask me but it is likely
to irritate the demon who thought he had
killed her then goku even promises that
they'll make sure to heal her of all her
emotional scars too then goku is clearly
like a shining example of idealism and
positivity you almost feel like you can
do anything in his presence and that's
just as significant as his actual power
as a hashira then goku is fast enough to
cut the demon's hands and release the
kid hostage since the slasher demon can
sense he's outmatched here he starts
using what he believes is his clear
advantage his super speed and starts
running towards the bento people that
goku clearly cares about so much then
goku makes sure everyone's okay and then
considerably after the demon left he
starts chasing after him on the tracks
he uses total concentration breathing
and blazes through the night too quick
for the human eye to follow although he
started way after it's easy to see that
he'll catch up to the slasher demon
despite that demon's confidence in his
own speed we jump to the slasher seeing
the girl vendor and the grandma throws a
bento box at him which is actually super
effective because he hates the smell of
human food so much the grandma did say
previously that she would gladly
sacrifice her life for that of her
granddaughter so this is pretty much her
doing just that while the girl runs but
the slasher does go for the girl he
grabs her by the throat and is about to
cut her when goku comes to the rescue he
not only saves the girl but manages to
cut the demon's leg too the demon is
shocked that goku was fast enough to
catch up so quickly and he probably
doesn't even know that he stood behind a
while after the demon had already left
then there's such an epic part where the
demon challenges rangoku to see if
rengoku can cut off his head before he
kills the grandmother rengoku says
there's no reason to put it to the test
because the demon is too slow and by the
time he's finished his sentence the
demon's head has already been cut off
it's such an awesome scene and i love
the fact that he called this demon who
is obsessed with his own speed too slow
it was the perfect thing to say he
completely shattered his confidence as
he took away his life it is only after
he's cut him that he says fire breathing
first form unknowing fire i appreciate
this because you always have dudes
saying their attacks in anime ahead of
time and giving it away but here he
attacked first and then said the name
after not giving the enemy time to
prepare in this case he shot when he was
supposed to shoot instead of talking and
i always appreciate that the grandma
also has flashbacks of rengoku although
it was kyojiro's father also saving her
and her daughter 20 years ago from a
demon so it is actually thanks to
kyogre's father that this grandmother
her daughter and this granddaughter are
alive today kyoto lets her know that
that was his dad and that he is
following in his footsteps another
important detail that will be very
relevant later on since one of the main
aspects of an goku's character arc is
his relationship with his family and
father he clearly has respect for his
father and says he's honored to have
protected them like his father did in
the past as the girl apologizes for not
believing her grandmother about the
demons then goku is positive again
saying there's no better way to live
than not believing and not running into
demons later we also figure out thanks
to rengoku that this demon was far too
weak to have devoured 40 people and
there is a far more powerful demon on
the mugen train which he'll board soon
and obviously everyone who watched the
movie knows exactly who this demon is he
runs into the vendors yet again and they
want to give him a free bento box he
wants to pay but they insist so he takes
that one for free and buys the rest of
the boxes he promises to tell his father
about them bringing him up yet again
showing he's often thinking about his
father then our main characters make an
appearance as inosuke is shocked by the
iron beast that is the train and
headbutts it to zanetsu's great
embarrassment meanwhile rengoku takes
his seat on the train we see some of the
sickly kids who will play a role in this
arc and the train takes off as if
telling us all aboard the new season of
demonstrator it's officially here then
goku digs in and screams delicious just
like he did in the manga and anime film
however by now in this version we have a
much better understanding of his
character of his kindness positivity and
bluntness it's a completely different
feeling than before and i like it like i
mentioned i feel like we know something
everyone else on the train doesn't about
and goku and it's a cool feeling now
after the new scenes we're watching him
eat as if he were a friend we care about
rather than as a supposedly strong
stranger and that is it a great start to
the new season with some great rengoku
original content let me know if you
enjoyed it and what you thought of the
brand new demon we got here do you
prefer this version or the old one where
we start with rangoku eating the bento
and in that version we don't even know
where the bento box came from this
version definitely makes the bento box
much more significant which i also
appreciate it we also get some extra
material after the episode of how the
other hashira think of it and goku
shinobu says he's a good person though
there are times where they are not on
the same wavelength and that to me is
clear he's blunt and honest while
shinobu can definitely hide her true
emotions tengen thinks and goku is
flamboyant and sticks out even more than
him which is a huge compliment for
tengen who is obsessed with being
flamboyant he also thinks that goku is a
really great guy muichiro thinks he's
like an owl and has a comforting voice
pretty out there answer what you'd
expect from muichiro pretty much mitsuri
says he's like a super cool older
brother and she had fun training with
him he would always dote on her that's a
cool detail too that they brought in
here you may not have known but then
goku was the one who trained mitsuri
before she became a hashira i like that
they included that detail here iguro
thinks he talks too much which is
probably the most negative thing anyone
said but igoro also loves him and thinks
he has a good personality sunimi also
thinks he's a good guy and loves him
gyome thinks he's positive never whines
and honest all high praise finally giu
also loves him and says that goku often
speaks to him and for a guy like gehu
who let's be honest is a bit short on
friends if you've seen all the memes you
know that probably means a lot to him
that someone talks to him and is trying
to make him feel like he belongs all in
all everyone loves the flame hasher and
goku he clearly spreads positivity and
love and although inosuke keeps
insisting on fighting him he loves him
too it's impossible not to love this
dude like mitsuri most of our main
characters view him as a big brother and
so as far as that in goku tribute
episode goes this was pretty awesome and
it will definitely serve to make what
happens in the mugen train arc hit us
even harder but that is it for this one
if you do want me to cover every episode
like this and review it let me know by
smashing that like button and leaving a
comment below along with suggestions for
other demonstra videos you'd like to see
remember that smashing that like button
is rengoku energy and passing is creepy
speed demon energy so choose wisely
don't be a creepy speed demon if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates and
while you wait for the next demonstrator
episode to drop feel free to check out
my huge and growing demonstrator
playlist that includes videos on all
hashira demon moons a video specifically
about how strong then goku is if you're
curious about that and much much more
link to that is in the description and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you